you know when you sign up for the
academy and they take you off the bus
the first thing they do is they line you
up and everybody gets their heads shaved
okay you're in the same uniform so when
you look the same you dress the same you
act basically the same you're in
formation the acmy take away all your
god-given rights and then give them back
to his privileges over the next four
years and the reason for that is you
have to realize what you're fighting for
the freedoms that we have the things
that we take for granted every day and
when you can't eat what you want to eat
or get up when you want to get up and
wear the clothes that you want to wear
and they slowly give them back to his
privileges you really find out what
makes being a free American so special
there's always somebody better than you
Chris you know when I talk about being a
wingman you look to your left and your
right and ask for help and that's what
being in the military and indion is all
about Rob Waldo Waldman is a decorated
fighter pilot with 65 combat missions
and
2,650 flight hours he's the New York
Times best-selling author of never fly
solo and an esteemed member of the
speaker Hall of Fame it's in this
exclusive interview with Chris Weidner
you'll hear Waldo's best advice on
building your leadership skills
embracing the push it up mentality for
Peak Performance and becoming your own
ultimate wingman and we've got Chris's
permission to put it up on our YouTube
channel enjoy Waldo thank you yeah good
to have you here I always like to have
uh folks that I've been friends with for
a number of years and you and I have
gotten to know each other the last
couple of years through some speaking
engagements and uh through the national
speaker Association so I'm excited to
let the audience know some of the things
that I know about you and uh glad to
have you here awesome good you know one
of the things we talked about starting
the the show with is to help America
kind of peer behind the veil that are
theems and you went to the United States
Air Force Academy and I thought it would
be fun for people to be able to kind of
sneak peek behind the scenes at what
takes place at the fourmies and
particularly from your perspective at
the Air Force Academy what are some of
the things that it takes to get into
theems and what are the unique lessons
that you feel like the young men and
women learned at these acmy that prepare
them for life that make them so
successful when they get out well as a
as a major in Air Force Reserve I'm
actually a admissions liaison officer
okay for the Academy so I interview
these young men and women with such
potential to be everything they want to
be so to speak and uh the toughest part
of their senior year in high school is
actually trying to get into the academy
is because it's a complicated admissions
process they have to go through
Congressional nominations interviews so
many steps how does how does that work
the Congressional cuz that's one of
things that I've heard is that you have
to have a a letter from your Congress
person right in addition to being
interviewed one-on-one just like we're
doing right here with a uh an academy
grad or liaison officer they have to go
through uh a Academy review board with
the congressman Andor his or her
Personnel the his wingman so to speak
and they asked the the this young man
and woman a lot of questions about their
background their values SAT scores
academics so many things to dig deep not
only into their ability to perform
perform well physically and academically
which the academy is are very
challenging in but also what is the core
what's behind that person and is this
person going to be able to make the
military a career and will they be able
to serve and do the mission which is
obviously as you know not not very easy
yeah what are the basic requirements for
getting into the theems I mean when I
think of theems I think of the crem de
laem the the very top the top SATs you
know student body president quarterback
of the NF or quarterback of the high
school football team what what is it
what's the basic requirements we look
for well-rounded individuals somebody
that can get into Harvard may not be
able to get into the Air Force Academy
if you're just purely academic that's
not enough officers in the military
especially when you're leading men and
women in a combat need to be diverse
resilience the ability to adapt to
change uh physically Adept uh
emotionally secure uh just a lot of
subtle things that you really get when
you talk to a young person about their
background so how how do you find that
when you're sitting across the table
from a 17-year-old how do you find
diversity the adaptability change how do
you how do you see that in a 17-year-old
kid you you look at their background uh
what type of activities were they
involved what's their their propensity
to achieve success how do they get along
with others and put them into various
situations and ask them what they would
do obviously anybody can make up stories
when they're uh in an interview or
whatever but really when you when you
put them in a situation and
uh find out how they would adapt and
respond as well as their past I think
you can assess a lot about their
character what's a day like at at one of
the cies What's a what's an average
Tuesday look like well one of the things
that's you know when
you sign up for the academy and they
take you off the bus the first thing
they do is they line you up and
everybody gets their heads shaved okay
you're in the same uniform it sort of
puts that whole equal playing field
right uh into your life the academy and
the reason why they do that is if it
really imparts the critical importance
of being a team player that it's not an
individual that wins it's the team so
when you look the same you dress the
same you act basically the same you're
in
formation that is really really critical
and that's how we live the four years
there as a group as a team now is that
get back to this idea that I read a book
uh can't remember the exact name but it
was on West Point and they they
basically said that everybody that comes
into the acmy is again creme de crem
they were the quarterback of the
football team student body president 3.8
4.0 and so they all come thinking
they're the cats me out and they're used
to being the leader they're used to
being standouts and now they're in a a a
group of peers who are all very similar
and so the idea is to say yeah you're
great and and you're been a great leader
but your your peers are also leaders is
that part of what they try to groom into
you absolutely you know they have a
saying at the
eies the acmy take away all your
god-given rights and then give them back
to his privileges over the next four
years and the reason for that is you
have to realize what you're fighting for
the freedoms that we have the things
that we take for granted every day and
when you can't eat what you want to eat
or get up when you want to get up and
wear the clothes that you want to wear
and they slowly give them back to as
privileges you really find out what
makes being a free American so special
and when they neutralize the playing
field you've got to earn your rank back
you've got to earn your way up and uh
there's always somebody better than you
Chris uh and that's a humbling
experience and you know when I talk
about being a wingman you look to your
left and your right and ask for help and
that's what being in the military and
being an American in my opinion is all
about so uh the day starts at as you
would say o Dark 30 dirty absolutely so
tell us tell us what would happen accom
I'll give you what it's like basically
as a fourth classman a freshman first
first year basically they get up and you
got to get your room in tip toop shape
and that includes after you brush your
teeth and you clean out the sink that
can't be any water in the the sink your
mirrors have to be perfect shoes shine
Etc a lot like my home bathroom
absolutely right uh and what happens is
you line up outside the hallways and the
fourth classman are there to call
minutes you you get all the upper
classman ready for their day you call
out the menu for the morning meal the
days until graduation how many minutes
till formation you have to know current
events three current events of the day
the days until Christmas etc etc so you
got to prepare before you walk out of
that room why the rot memorization and
the typical American would consider that
rot memorization how many days till
Christmas and etc etc what is the
purpose of that CU I know that that's a
a big part of the training in the
academies what is the purpose of that
rope memorization it's about handling
yourself and and doing things under
pressure because in the military in
combat you've got to handle yourself and
do things under pressure you got to
memorize the weather the target who's
your wing what are the frequencies what
are the things you need to do and we
start early and if you can't memorize
the current events or your days until
graduation you're probably not going to
be able to do it m as a as a as an oper
classman or as as an officer in combat
so we put the young men in women under
pressure for four years and uh when
somebody's asking you these questions
you know days of graduation then you're
you're stressed out well can you execute
under that and then we teach these men
and women how to execute Under Pressure
because you're going to make mistakes we
want them to make mistakes but uh for
example when we talk about the wingman
when a fourth classman is messing up his
wingman his other fourth class to come
over there and and help him okay and
memorize the days until graduation cuz
you never could do it alone there's
always somebody there so it's just a
great feeling and it's very symbolic
like I said of how you can live your
life and your career as an officer and
and I've applied it to my personal lives
as well so you march the breakfast you
uh uh has a fourth class when you got
what's typical breakfast you've got like
12 minutes to eat and do everything it's
not a lot is a big pile of mush they
give you like in the movies it's family
style great food the academy uh they
really take nutrition uh seriously and
everybody shares and uh the Freshman
normally don't get too much deep but it
just depends you know uh and then you
know it's like a normal College day uh
but we we separate today 50-minute
periods academics we march to to lunch
we have uh academic caller Quarters at
night inter murals military training
later on in the afternoon it depends and
then uh other than the Academic Year the
Summers you have specific programs you
travel across the country over to Europe
uh as fourth classman you go through uh
during your freshman to summer or
freshman to sophomore year you go
through series survival evasion
resistance Escape where they put you
through a mock uh P situation uh and God
willing none none of us will have to do
that but as we know now there's it's
it's serious out there so we prepare
early so that when they're out there in
the real world they'll be able to
succeed so lots of programs lots of
opportunities for leadership uh and
you're always challenged when you think
back to your days that the academy
what uh what one two maybe three
principles that you learned at the
Academy have stuck with you most in your
life today one of the most important
components of the academy is the honor
code MH we will not lie steal or cheat
nor tolerate Among Us anyone who does
and that mission statement so to speak
really is ingrained in us for those four
years and it's something I've taken back
in my into my personal professional life
as well they understand the academy that
you're going to make mistakes and no
one's perfect but the older you get the
more experience you get the more
responsibility you get the less those
mistakes are going to be acceptable so
you learn the the importance of honor
and integrity and and and accountability
and when you're out there in the
business World in my opinion there's no
black or white or there's no gray area
for for integrity it's either black or
white you're honest or you're not and at
the end of the day you've got to be
honest with yourself uh and be able to
look yourself in the mirror and know
you're doing the right thing and as men
and women you know today with the Enron
the world comms accountability Integrity
are very uh you know they're put to the
test and a lot of people fail uh that's
one of the most important things I've
learned there now I know that when you
travel around the country which you do
quite a bit you've been a professional
speaker for just a few years at this
point uh making the transition from the
business world that we mentioned in the
in the intro but have been very
successful uh jumping right in and and
traveling all over the country speaking
for all the major corporations fact
after this you're going to jump on an
airplane and off to another another
engagement and the primary thing that
you talk about is being a wingman and
we're going to get to a lot of those
principles but one of the things I found
that's interesting as I sit here and
talk to people like yourself is how much
our upbringing affects who we are today
and so you uh are going to tell us a
little bit about your upbringing and how
even at an early age through High School
you had these themes of being a wingman
and having a wingman as part of your
life so tell us a little bit about what
it was like growing up in your home and
where you grew up and that type of thing
uh I was the youngest of four children I
have an older brother Steve and a sister
Leslie they're married and have kids
wonderful people and I also have an
identical twin Dave and he's been my
wingman in my whole life uh when you're
a kid you always got somebody to play
with you always have somebody to cry on
and do stuff with so so the whole
wingman concept really started at an
early age for me my parents uh uh grew
up very poor in in New York City as you
can tell my acent I'm not from Alabama
yeah exactly uh I noticed that you know
it was always about education always
about family always about depending on
each other because that's how you
succeed in life you know but my twin
brother Dave was always there for me and
still is today my number one confident
my number one wingman you were in
business with him for a while yeah in
the merger and acquisition they've
taught me everything I know now and I'm
trying to teach him a few things but uh
he's somebody that I can always call up
and ask for help did pretty well well in
high school academically and and
physically I I did a lot of sports
soccer which always talks about the team
concept track Etc and then I was also a
musician in band I was in Jazz Ensemble
marching band uh and obviously when
you're a musician you're just one
component of a whole piece and I really
enjoy that uh I think that a lot of
people they agree with the idea of
teamwork and the general principle being
a wingman but they don't really realize
how much everything we do is based on
this idea that we have to have other
people involved and those are the
lessons that you learned growing up
playing sports being in band uh those
types of things right well I think a
fallacy that a lot of people may have in
my opinion I think to be the best
wingman the trusted partner both in
business and in life you've got to be
your own wingman I call it getting in
touch with the inner wingman know and
you know if you're not prepared if you
haven't done the things necessary to to
grow spiritually mentally academically
physically whatever it takes at the end
of the day you've got to do it yourself
arold Schwarzenegger says you know no
one ever got big watching me lift the
weight
you've got to do it on your own and the
best way in my opinion to be a team
player is to do your job the best of
your ability become prepared on a
personal level and then you can
contribute to the team then you can be
that person that people can call out to
and ask for help but it all starts with
you but uh you can't do it on your own
obviously and you need those other men
and women in your life to be there for
you to win so your wingman are expecting
you to to take care of them but really
they're expecting you to take care of
yourself without doubt without doubt you
know as a fighter pilot when we flew our
combat
I wanted to know if I was fine with You
Chris that Chris wner took the time to
study the threat he prepared he got the
8 to 12 hours of sleep he's serious
about the mission and if I saw you
slacking off and not doing what's
necessary to win I'm not going to want
to fly with you now that that comes back
to the training the academy the fighter
pilot training all the things that we do
with 33% failure rate and wash out rate
in the military and fighter training so
by the time you take the step to lead me
on a mission or to be my wingman you're
ready you're prepared and I can say
Chris we're going to do this together
and I want you to back me up and check
my six for the threat and I'll do the
same for you let's push it up now I've
went to your uh Speech here a couple U I
guess about a couple weeks ago you were
in Seattle and came out and and watched
you do your thing it was great stuff and
you did the push it up uh with the
audience and they loved it I thought it
was kind of funny anybody can get an
audience to do a a kind of a a group
activity like that I'm impressed with so
what's push it up what's that mean push
it up basically
when you're flying in formation and on a
mission push it up means add power get
in a position let's run down track let's
let's speed it up and it's very
analogous
to life because when you get up in the
morning it's not easy sometimes with all
the pressures and the situations the the
the things that we have to deal with
every day on on on a personal
professional level so you got to say
push it up I got to make it happen so
what I do is I get my the my audiences
to push it up with me and it's funny
it's a it's a little thing we used to do
before every mission in Korea where I
flew in the 35th Fighter Squadron
pantons I spent a year and before every
Mission we would give each other the
Hang Loose sign okay and that hang loose
sign was symbolic of the eyes of that
black panther okay which was our
Squadron mascot yeah and while
simultaneously thrusting our hands
forward as if we were going to full
power on the throttles we yell out in a
loud and thunderous Air Force voice push
it up yeah to show that we ready to take
the fight to the enemy and win so what I
get my audiences to do is three to do
push it up together yeah in one unified
voice and some of them think it's a
little funny or cheesy but then that's
the point because it's not easy right to
push it up every day you've got to psych
yourself out in your mind first and win
in your mind first before you can go out
and Win For Real excellent so after you
graduated from US Air Force Academy then
what got accepted into pilot training
and that's not the easiest thing either
because you not only have to do pretty
well at the Academy but you also have to
be medically fit uh went to Pilot
Training in Phoenix and then fortunately
did well there and they asked me to stay
on as an instructor pilot teaching
instructor pilot and flying fundamentals
to young men and women who just went out
of the academy and just finished uh uh
their initial screening so I did that
for a few years taught the young men and
women and then was asked to be an
instructor instructor pilot teaching
future instructors the fundamentals of
instruction which is completely
different when you think about it how to
teach these young men and women how to
fly and understanding that
individuals are different they need
different things to motivate and Inspire
them different things to drive them to
success so uh that was also a great
Challenge and I really really enjoyed
that cuz I got to meet a lot of other
experienced officers and Air Force
pilots who did other things before
becoming an instructor as well so when
you're instructing these kids uh what
what are you doing there is it is it
classroom stuff or you actually putting
them in a jet and going up a little bit
of everything one-on-one instruction
just like this putting them under
pressure asking them the questions
because if you can't handle it sipp in a
cup of uh cold water
oneon-one then you're definitely not
going to be able to handle it under
pressure in in a combat environment or
in the weather or at night so we do a
lot of one-on-one instruction and then
we do a lot of simulation training and
then we jump in the jet before you jump
in the jet you're ready to rock and roll
so it's uh a lot of different components
and I spend a lot of time after hours on
the weekends just sitting down with
these men and women because flying isn't
as easy as some may think the the
fundamentals are easy but all the things
behind the scenes the system the Weapons
Systems in an F16 the the tactics the
technology the is so much that goes on
behind the scenes so uh a lot to it do
you remember the first time they handed
you the keys the keys to one of those
bad boys and and it was just you and no
longer other people nobody else and
there you go it was your first flight I
I I remember uh remember it like it was
yesterday but the I flew you know the
Cessna and then the t37 and then I flew
the F-16 but F-16 solo flight was by far
the most memorable because where were
you was it early morning it was early
morning Phoenix Arizona beautiful crisp
day I think it was uh like November or
so back a few years ago yeah and I just
remember sitting in this $30 million jet
looking over the nose looking down my
wing line and just thinking this is so
cool I can't believe they trust me to do
this yeah and I was hoping that my
instructor pilot wasn't thinking the
same thing he believed in me right his
name was Dee Slayton he lives in Atlanta
Georgia and uh uh just in amazing
amazing person you know the confidence
you build with these folks that you're
flying with both your instructors your
flight leads your wingmen the trust and
confidence in them to get the job done
you you can't put a price tag on that
and that's what I Inspire in my
audiences and my clients you know what
does it take to build that confidence
what does it take to build that trust so
that when you go out on your missions in
life to win and it takes a Sac a lot of
sacrifice and a lot of work you just
don't wake up being a Top Gun sure yeah
in fact uh that was one of the other
things I wanted to talk to you about
there's was a movie I don't know if you
ever saw it a few years ago I don't know
I always wonder do do they consider the
movie a pro or a con movie topcon well
you know I'm definitely not Tom Cruz
right but uh the thing about Top Gun it
was a great movie A lot of the stuff was
realistic in there
but a lot of things that you might see
in the movie aren't really uh true with
regarding the real world military the
real world Top Gun stuff okay no fighter
pilot ever flies a combat Mission solo
we always always always fly as a team
with that wingman and the thing that I
really emphasize that maybe Top Gun
didn't emphasize are all the things
behind the scenes with your other
wingman on on the ground the maintenance
troops your Intelligence Officers the
weather Personnel the security policeman
guarding the base at night so you can
sleep before I strap on that jet there's
a lot of things that came into place
that that came together so I can go go
up there and be confident and execute
that mission and when you look at that
in life and in the business world for
example if I'm a sales manager which I
was for a few years there was customer
service tech support Human Resources
Finance all those individual components
within a company that are critical to
getting the job done and if you don't
build relationships with them if you
don't understand how their role fits in
the big picture if you don't appreciate
them then I don't truly think you're
building that relationship and
confidence to win um top gum was a great
movie and I loved it but at the end of
the day there's more about winning in
battle than just the guys and gals on
the front line so what was your uh what
was your nickname you had it painted on
the side of your jet it's obviously
Waldo my last name wal and you got to
earn that nickname and and they say you
know uh you either earn it by doing
something really stupid or you earn it
by being in combat or whatever and I
admit I've done
both but Waldo's the one that St the one
thank goodness what uh you've earned Top
Gun what does it take to earn Top Gun
what what's that
a lot of different Top Gun Awards Top
Guns mean means you're the best in that
particular segment and I I was an airr
Top Gun in one of the training programs
I went through you know bombs closest to
the Target airmanship situational
awareness where you are and and relative
to all your other wingmen listening on
the radio is just your ability to adapt
in this environment and they rate you
and you get awarded it but as a you know
even if you take second place as a fight
a pilot isn't bad as well yeah exactly
so you flew F16 and 65 combat missions
but over 2,000 flights out doing your
standard training and that type of thing
flew in Iraq and flew in Bosnia correct
tell us a little bit about that what
what is that like I would imagine that
um even though your training has
designed you to to go out that still
going out and knowing that you're
defending your country and doing what's
right but at the same time knowing that
you might end a life that day uh is not
something that is is so Cavalier that we
sometimes see in the movies that there's
a real sense and I know you well enough
to know that there's a deep sense of
responsibility and tell us a little bit
about what that feels like to be going
out flying a a mission a combat Mission
and what's going through your mind in
all the different areas combat is not a
fun thing and it's something that uh
it's really where the rubber meets the r
when you're in the military we've got
young men and women in in Iraq now and
Afghanistan putting their lives on the
Laine every single day you know and the
training component is critical because
at the end of the day your training
takes over and if you don't feel
comfortable in your training you're not
going to be confident and if you're not
confident you're going to be
fearful and fear is a byproduct of that
training and also of your attitude and
the attitude that you have when you go
on a combat is going to determine your
success without a doubt and I'm telling
you I was afraid every Mission I went on
my wingmen were afraid everybody that
serves is afraid it's called being a
human being right and that fear
was so it just can strangle you okay but
to you know to adapt to the fear and
just deal with it and still execute was
something I was critical and what I used
to do before my missions and I still do
when I'm doing other challenging
situations is I I do what's called turn
my fear into
Focus focusing on the right things to
get the job done first I I focus on the
mission you know when I strapped into my
jet in Yugoslavia flying 7-hour night
missions the mission wasn't about me it
was about the poor men and women who
were being murdered and and and
pillaged you know in in Serbia they
needed me to bring wack their freedom so
it starts when you're on the tarmac
you've got a lineup of how many AB we've
got well there was four four other
aircraft flying with me plus another of
six to 12 other you know stealth
Fighters tankers probably a whole slew
of of aircraft and so when you're
sitting there obviously you're you're
making a check down of the flight
instruments but at the same time you're
focusing and developing your attitude
for this is what this is about you got
you know in the back of your mind you're
thinking about it doesn't just start in
the jet it starts when you go to bed at
night when you wake up in the morning
you're just psyching yourself out saying
okay this is my job you know you want to
be Top Gun and training big deal this is
where it happens you know in life we
talk about philosophies and execution
blah blah blah but when the rubber meets
the road and the job gets has to get
done this is what separates the you know
the average people the men from the boys
the women from the the girls okay where
you know it's time to execute so what
I'm saying is fear is normal your
attitude is going to take over and you
got to put your attitude in the right
place and focus is what it's about focus
on the mission the purpose it's not
about you it's those that you're serving
looking down my wing line you know with
the in the F-16 now this is cool and
when I looked down and I saw those folks
that I was going to fly with it filled
me with courage knowing that they were
going to be there for me knowing that I
could count on them if the missiles
launched or if I screwed up God forbid
they were going to be there to say
wallow I got your cover I got your six
I'm looking behind you don't worry about
it yeah and just as important was they
needed me yeah because if I messed up
Chris and I didn't do my job then I was
going to fail in their and protecting
them so and in combat they talk about
you're you know you're afraid of dying
whatever you're more afraid of messing
up and and and having your wingmen get
shot down than it is about yourself it's
totally selfless I'm telling and
thinking about their spouses their
children and you want to get them home
to their spouses and children the same
way you that they're going to get you
home to your family doubt and that's
ultimately the the wingman that you f
for who are you fing for at home yeah
you know the loved ones that's what it's
about it's not about combat and killing
it's about doing the mission getting
home to to to be with those that we love
that is maybe one of the downsides to
Hollywood and the way they've portrayed
a lot of combat is that there is a lot
of you know just sort of glory and
basking in the the explosions and the
killing and you know the retribution and
and all that kind of stuff and in real
life it's it's much more sober than
without a doubt I don't believe in the
saying business is combat or life is
combat combat isn't Fun there's lives
lost there's walls built there's
barriers there's resentments if you have
a combative nature and think about
combat and everything that you do
there's winners and losers I'm going to
crush the enemy I'm going to crush you
know in business the companies talk
about crushing the competition but you
know what today the competitor could be
an ally in a partner tomorrow MH so you
got to be cognizant of those
relationships hey compete fairly
with Integrity with compassion and
honesty but you never know if you're
really doing things that are going to
soil the relationship with a future
partner you better think twice in
business today it's more strategic than
that it's about cooperation
communication and commitment not just
about combat it's just it's just not
what I think is important hey there it's
Chris Weidner and I hope that you're
enjoying this interview that I did with
one of the legends of personal
development and if you'd like even more
information and great resources from the
legends of personal development all you
have to to do is click on the link below
in the description and I've got a plenty
more for you so with that let's get back
to the interview so overcoming fear
first was Focus then what and then you
focus on your wingman okay those those
folks in your life that you're there for
you that you can turn to and ask the
three most important words in the
English language other than I love you
which is I need help tough for phop
pilot to ask for help tough for real
Macho men and women you know who are
doing so so great to ask for help but
you need to do that and then finally you
got to focus on winning winning not
surviving cuz surviving isn't Fun you
got to focus on winning and envision in
your mind everything going as well as
possible chair flying I I talk about I
don't know if we ever discussed that in
detail talk talk a little bit about
chair flying part of winning uh you know
winning happens in your mind first
before you do it for real and what we do
as fight apilot is we chair fly we
Mission rehearse we sit in the chair or
wherever we are in the car restroom
doesn't make a difference and we go
through the mission in perfect detail in
our mind and we don't just Envision it
going perfectly we picture making
mistakes we picture messing up a radio
call we we picture not getting the right
air speed and engage in the proper
systems and then we go back and do it
again from A to Z so that by the time
I'm done making the mistakes and fixing
them because we're going to make
mistakes in real life right we can do it
as perfectly as we can so by envisioning
it when you go out there for real you
can do it and same thing that goes for
for basketball players or for for
surgeons sales managers who who are out
there briefing a mission or having a
one-on-one sales briefing with a
potential million dollar client I'm
contingency planning I'm asking myself
what if things don't go well what if you
ask me a question about price and value
what if uh my my laptop fails do I have
a backup plan or the surgeon is doing an
operation and they suddenly go into
cardiac arrest or something like that
you talk about um perfect preparation as
opposed to perfect execution is that
right I the whole Flawless preparation
as opposed to Flawless execution a
Flawless execution is a big business
term and it rarely happens doesn't it it
rarely happens now
ideally Flawless
execution is we we want that all the
time every fighter pilot wants false
execution although we never fly a
perfect mission but I think when we put
the pressure on our on our wingman in in
a company for example and we say falsey
EX our mission this year is Flawless
execution that's a high standard isn't
it sure and as a human being we're
probably not going to be Flawless
especially when you have 4,000 people in
your unit or you know even as a small uh
a small business you have 18 people
working there 15 people you're not going
to have that over over the course of a
year so when you make a mistake and
don't achieve the objective of flawless
execution when you make mistakes what
happens to your attitude more often than
not you kind of get down you get down
and when you're down what happens to
your attit attitude you get more more
down more down and and you become more
fearful you're afraid to take risks
you're afraid to to to reveal your true
self you're afraid to push it up so
rather than push for flawless execution
I say push for flawless preparation
gather your intelligence brief your
missions make sure you understand your
environment study the threat do all the
things you need to do behind the scenes
Mission rehearse chair fly sweat and
sacrifice on the ground so that when you
go out there that Flawless preparation
will eventually and hopefully lead to
Flawless
execution so it's a psychological shift
push for flawless preparation that'll
lead your people to be more inspired and
fired up willing to take risks and do
what's necessary to achieve near
Flawless execution yeah one of my goals
with the show here is to have people
like yourself who've achieved so much in
life and been so successful is to bring
them in and let people get to know the
real story cuz often times we see you
know we look at Waldo and we go you know
Air Force Academy grad fighter pilot Top
Gun successful business person decides
he's going to get into speaking and now
he's taken the speaking World by storm
and you know that and you go wow
wouldn't it be great to be Waldo but
then they don't realize the things that
have happened behind the scenes that
you've had to overcome and one of the
things that I would like for you to talk
a little bit about is what you call your
significant emotional experience and I
think that's really going to help people
because they're going to realize that
you didn't get to to do and be what
you've done without having to really
overcome some significant challenges
particularly as it pertains to the
profession of a fighter pilot so tell us
about that what happened to you there
and and how your Evolution uh of your
life and career came to overcome those
things okay I have a saying I talk about
in my presentations the more you sweat
in peace the less you believe in war the
more you sweat in peace the less you
believe more and all the things you do
behind the scenes the sacrifices and the
things you have to overcome to allow you
to go out there and ex excute with as
minimal bleeding as possible yeah uh we
all have challenges in life things that
we have to overcome when I was uh three
years into my flying career I went scuba
diving down in the Caribbean you know in
those quick 2hour courses that you hear
that maybe you even participated in well
I'm not necessarily a fish in the water
I'm you know I've got some challenges
but I'm okay I grew up outside the
Atlantic Ocean but I went and I went on
a scuba diving trip and long story short
uh
I went under 35 ft accidentally sucked
in basically a whole lung full of water
and had a panic attack 35 ft under the
ground saw Stars my heart was panic I
thought I was literally going to die it
was it was traumatic for me and I never
had a panic attack before in my life
then and I'm like I have got to go up
now needless to say absolutely traumatic
for me I got up out of the water saying
that's the last time I'm ever going to
scuba dive again my confidence was
shattered uh uh and I literally thought
I was going to die a few weeks later I
was flying in the uh t37 flying on a on
a training sorty and you you'd been
flying for three years at this years so
you were comfortable with the
comfortable never had about with any you
know never had issues it was my life
yeah and I had a panic attack uh flying
around 20,000 ft basically I I started
feeling
claustrophobic not a good thing for a
fight not a good thing and uh I realized
then Chris that I had latent
claustrophobia that had come out that
that significant event dying and almost
dying in that scuba diving accident
brought it out and for the next few
years in particular for the next several
months I was faced with dealing with
that claustrophobia strapping on that
plane teaching men and women how to fly
dealing with that and and just putting
that whole claustrophobia that panic and
also I'm afraid of heights that's a
whole another story I grew up another
thing maybe being uh being a pilot at
30,000 ft might not uh be conducive too
but those are great lessons because
people get into situations in in
business and they think that they have
to be perfect or they have to have
everything settled and it's not so much
about having all their issues settled
it's about dealing with them and
overcoming them and being successful in
spite of them right so how did you do
that you know you're claustrophobic fear
of heights and they're sticking you in a
small little space at 30,000 ft how do
you do that
passion not
quitting when my passion for flying was
so strong I wouldn't I would I refuse to
let it take control of me you have
opportunities in your life to let your
your fears take over or to let your
passion and your and your and your love
for whatever it is you're doing take
over if I would have gave into that
claustrophobia and didn't do all the
things that I talked about focusing on
the mission it's not about me and
becoming so Adept and psychologically
defeating this claustrophobia reading
books putting myself in situations
focusing on my my student focusing on my
wingman I love flying so much that it
was taking the joy out of my life I
wanted to love flying I wanted to enjoy
it so and flying did bring me joy so my
passion was so strong I didn't give in
to my fear and that's what I think we
need to do in life and in business and
in our relationships be so passionate
about what you're doing that you don't
care about anything else except
accomplishing this people are passionate
about business people are passionate
about dogs animals nature uh whatever
don't give into the fear because at the
end of the day when you go to bed at
night you're going to close your eyes
and say I'm not being true to who I am
and I'm not being true to what I need
and want in my life and if you let fear
control you you're never going to be
able to be a success so how do you do
that and let's get real practical is it
a matter like when you got in that jet
and you're claustrophobic and they drop
the lid on you and you're in there and
did you did you feel a sense of it like
uhoh I'm in this tight space now and
then you you just focused in let's make
some some uh examples of how people in
real life who go out maybe they're
afraid to cold call I know you were
saying you've got a new thing you're
going to start doing called turn your
cold call into a bold call people hate
cold calling right so and they're
they're looking at their phone and
they're thinking oh I got to do this
call but then they focus and they pick
up the how do you do that how do you
really get over your fear it it like I
said before it all has to do with what
you do before the scenes the sweat and
sacrifice the preparation the training
the discipline many people aren't
willing to do what it takes to
discipline themselves to to prepare for
their missions like I said before before
I strapped in that jet I would think
about my mission I would think okay I'm
going to be claustrophobic this is a
reality this is the truth acknowledging
the truth acknowledging that you're
going to be fearful and things are going
to happen is so important when you have
resistance that's what causes stress and
anxiety and panic and fear when you
acknowledge it you say okay I'm going to
get claustrophobic today come on I used
to say to myself bring it on you're
going to get all right come on okay I'm
feeling CLA strobic okay done and I
would let it flow through my system
acknowledge it rather than resist it and
then psychologically get myself in gear
Focus okay Rob stop being selfish it's
not about you you've got a mission to do
you want to be a fighter pilot it's not
about you get out of your own mind think
of the mission think of those that
you're serving and then okay I'm a
little afraid right now I got my wingman
there they're going to check me out if I
start having a problem I'll say two I
got a problem I need to okay wall I got
you right that's nice to know it's nice
to look over your shoulder when you're
in a stressful situation and a Clos in a
big business deal and you pick up the
phone and talk to your VP and say I need
help bro help me out I got your cover
Chris you talk to your wife or your
husband and say listen I'm under an
environment right now can you help me
out that that feels good to know that
somebody's there it they absorb your
fear and then lastly I think about
winning I know that it's going to be a
stressful s hours but I know at the end
of that 7even hours when I grab that
Italian cappuccino in Italy where I
threw my missions I'm going to sit down
and I'm going to go I earned this this
feels great this feels so much better
than it would have felt if I didn't go
on that mission I gave into my fears and
went to bed you know so I fill myself
with those positive endorphins and I oh
this is great and and that's those are
kind of some of the steps that you need
to do so really is mental discipline you
were you were basically choosing to
change your thoughts and by changing
your thoughts you change your whole
environment yes but it's it's not you
people say confront your fears do them
in spite of your fears you know I talk
more about courage and courage despite
feeling all that that anxiety and fear
is important but there has to be a
process that's why I say Mission wingman
winning and think about it shift shift
shift because you mind can't think about
multiple things at once it can only
focus on one thing and when you're so
engulfed that's why they talk about you
know being in the present you know
people like athletes fighter pilots
surgeons you know they're so engulfed in
the moment they're so focused they don't
think about all those auxiliary demons
that are going on the monkeys in our
mind being focused uh in life is is one
of the most critical components to
success but as a step and a process
takes discipline work uh and eventually
you become you'll train your mind and
that will eventually lead to more of a
successful mindset you'll become more
successful in other things you do let's
talk about some of the terms that you
learned in the military and as a fighter
pilot and now you apply in your speeches
and your Consulting to business
environment check six tell us about that
that's one big you heard me mention it a
couple times before six o'clock if you
think of a clock six o'clock's behind
you okay and in combat that's where the
threat was coming nine times out of 10
behind you where you don't see it you're
always looking over your shoulder for
the threat 75% of the time we're looking
outside the cockpit not looking folder
in our instruments but just as important
as a threat Chris are my wingman mile
away maybe right on my wing tip and I'm
monitoring them I'm looking behind them
because the threat might be coming to
them if if I'm directly behind it's hard
for me to see behind my back right and
I'm fly especially strapped in an F-16
especially Going H one yeah
right but if you're flying a mile away
from me and I could just go like this
and look behind you and you could just
go like that and look behind me Mutual
support I can see things behind you that
you can't see and we need each other to
accomplish the mission we're always
backing each other up Mutual support I'm
checking your six you're checking mine
and if you take that to
life when I'm flying in formation with
that man or woman and we're doing that
mission we we brief the mission we train
together we trust each other we know
we're going to be there for each other
and if you have a wingman that you're
flying with on your business missions
your husband and wife your kids whatever
they're looking at you to be their
wingman there's there's a lot that goes
behind being a wingman you know people
say Hey I'm your wingman well there's a
lot to say you're a wingman a trusted
partner you better be trained you better
be preparing you better be in your own
uh flying your own jet perfectly and I
better trust you when you're in business
and in life uh to be a wingman means to
be there for each other and uh I think
when you when you're dealing with a
situation a stressful environment at
work when you talk to the person next
door to you in the cubicle next door
your supervisor ask for help fly a
mission together that's kind of the same
thing and it all starts with checking
six and building that Mutual support how
can you in a in a corporate environment
or even a small
business we we're we're continually told
to take care of your own you know take
this is your realm you take care of it
I'm not so sure that the whole Czech six
idea has made it to Corporate America um
how can they apply that what can they do
how do you set that up do is it just
something that leadership has to talk
about do you have to set up systems so
that people so that the sales team is
looking out for the finance team and you
know everybody's looking out for each
other how does that work it's a tough
not the crack so to speak and they talk
about silos sales marketing tech support
engineering R&D and they're often in
different buildings yes I talk about a
couple things obviously when you have
annual meetings quarterly meetings
people need to understand how their role
fits in to the big picture yeah I used
to VI a VPS sales with a payroll tax
consulting company payroll tax you know
not the most exciting thing for X
fighter pilot to do sure yeah one day
you're flying an F-16 the next day
you're working on payroll tax that's
another story
but you know payroll and HR they're so
critical in getting the job done because
if people aren't getting their checks on
time and people aren't getting paid and
they can't deal with all the human
resource issues there that's going to
affect the morale the attitude of the
rest of the company uh people only
complain to the payroll folks when
they're not getting their checks on time
but really what can I do to bring that
bring a sense of passion and inspiration
to those payroll folks bring them in let
other people appreciate them if I'm in
sales let me go out with my pay manager
my tech support my uh customer service
agent let me learn what you do in your
business and you can learn what I do in
mine I tell my clients find a wingman in
another segment of your company and take
them out to lunch every month every
month go to lunch and just ask them
about what they do and it's going to
increase your Lev your depth of your
organization understand different roles
and then more importantly you'll have
somebody to turn to if you have an issue
with tech support customer service Hey
Joe this is wall we had lunch a couple
times last month or whatever I have a I
need help so that's really really
important do those little things allow
people to feel important in their
organization uh and really really really
like you mentioned before it's
ultimately up to the leadership because
it all starts from the top and goes down
but you know the idea that you just gave
of somebody in the sales department
calling somebody from the finance
department and all the different
departments taking them out for lunch
once a month that's actually probably a
pretty good plan for Upward Mobility if
you if you want to raise up the ranks if
you're knowing what's going on in these
other groups you're not only going to be
able to do your job better but you
you're going to become kind of a go-to
person cuz you're going to know you're
going to have a broader understanding
what's taking place in the corporate
environment takes time and effort it
does uh but something when you do that
it builds more loyalty within the
organization it improves my attitude it
makes me want to sweat more In Peace So
I don't bleed more it's going to bring
me uh to do the necessary things to win
let's talk about contingency planning
when we brief our missions like I
mentioned before we contingency plan we
sit down no filot ever starts a mission
before we brief we set objectives we
understand the weather the environment
the timeline we allocate roles and
responsibilities to the other members of
our formation and then we contingency
plan we basically say all right Chris
we're going on a twoip formation today
here's our Target these are objectives
etc etc now if I get shot down for
whatever reason God forbid you guys
actually say that without a doubt yeah
you have to you have to address it right
nobody wants to but you have to we you
got to be real right okay uh if my
engine quits I need you to do X Y and Z
if the weather changes here's our
alternate field if the Sam goes from an
sa 2 to an sa 6 this is what we can do
if uh if I'm on fire whatever whatever
and then I need to brief you hey if I
mess up you're the deputy flight lead
you take over and Lead me how many folks
in business have Deputy flight leads how
many managers I talk to every every
month that don't have somebody they can
turn to to take over God forbid
something happens to them they get sh
down they lose their job or they have to
take off a week cuz their kid kid is ill
and they need to focus more on their
family Deputy flight leads important so
we think about all these things on the
ground and discuss them plan them out so
when it happens in the heat of battle we
can respond because time is critical so
when you contingency plan like I said a
um a sales call you contingency plan a
corporate meeting a merger an
acquisition financials whatever you plan
them on the ground you take the time to
do them and then you you can execute
them more more efficiently when it
really happens you mentioned Sams and
you had an experience with uh a couple
of them and then a follow-up couple of
them tell us about that what happened
there uh April 28th 1999 and uh flying
out of Aviano in Italy I flew a mission
into Belgrade this was during Allied
Force operation Allied Force against
lanan mosovich and we were targeted I
was supporting a group of F-117 Stealth
fighters who were taking out strategic
Targets in downtown Belgrade I had four
wingmen we flying with and I was number
two you know you cross the FEA the
forward edge of the battle area into
enemy territory you go Master arm hot
and you're like okay this is it time to
do it and uh around 2 minutes crossing
the battle my radar warning receiver
went off I look out and no kidding I see
two big red fireballs coming up at me
just surfaced air missil surfaced air
missiles coming up shooting at me and it
was the proverbial you know kill or be
killed this is the moment of your life
Waldo that you have got to execute how
many times has that happen in real life
when this is it this is your moment of
glory and never like that though but
still things that are crucial for people
so I I I did my maneuver I lowered the
nose G gained the air speed and tried to
do all the procedures floundered screwed
up left and right but I did it enough
tell us what you do when that happens
okay well basically you got to lower
your nose and this is the unclassified
version you gain airp speed because
speed is life in an F-16 you lower the
nose and what you're trying to do is
basically gain enough energy and
maneuver to break the radar
lock which that's missile tracking on
you and also cause it to run out of
energy as it cor corrects on you okay so
you do these Maneuvers twist turn make a
radio call to build the situational Wess
telling the other folks you know scar
two missile launch right 3:00 my
wingman's 5 miles behind me he knows
he's in front of me right 3:00 is there
m and obviously he probably saw those
two red fireballs coming up at me as
well right cuz it was night and I do all
those procedures okay the missiles blew
up around 1,000 ft from my aircraft I
saw him explode like I call them like
sparklers you see on the 4th of July and
I remember thinking to myself it was at
that moment in time that particular
second where I I thought
like I defeated the most incredible
threat the first real no kidding threat
of my life it was totally surreal and I
will never forget how it felt
um 5 minutes later we rejoined up and I
got into another pattern another two
missiles were launched on me yeah good
thing you settled the first two cuz you
had another two I felt a little more
confident but uh you know when you when
I was able to defeat that threat it gave
me more confidence I was I was able to
do a much better job and you know and
that's very analogous to life as well
yeah you have a missile launch at you
one day it's going to happen again you
got to be able to deal with them execute
under the pressure and feel good about
it CU When you're feeling good and the
endorphins are flowing through your mind
correctly and you feel confident you're
able to execute your mission and the
procedures necessary a lot easier than
if you're t and scared and Afraid you
know afraid to uh to get killed yeah the
first time you do anything or the first
time you experience anything is a little
difficult they might experience a little
fear but by successfully achieving it
the first time then the second time I I
don't know that uh looking down and
seeing served air missiles ever becomes
routine but it becomes much easier for
you to handle because you've already
conquered it once absolutely that's
similar in life yeah uh let's talk about
the process that you think is also good
for corporate environment of briefing
and debriefing right well we talked
about briefing you know sitting down
before the missions and setting the
contingencies and going out next uning
but when we come back from our mission
the critical component of accomplishing
a successful mission is the debrief
where you sit down at a table like this
we take off our rank because there has
to be an equal playing field and we
discuss everything from A to Z
everything we talked about in the
briefing and the planning all the way
down to the execution landing and taxi
back and we do this debriefing as a way
to close the learning Gap
Okay the reason why we take off our rank
so to speak and we have an EV even
playing field is that if you're my
commander my squadron commander Colonel
and I was a flight lead that day and
anybody could be a flight lead as long
as they went through the program and
earned that that uh privilege if I can't
put you in a position where we feel on
an equal playing field if I think that
your rank is going to intimidate me from
telling you how it is you know Chris you
want in a position
and I told you to break right and you
didn't break right was there something
wrong with your radios why didn't you do
it and you need to be able to tell me w
i i i wasn't paying attention I was
focusing somewhere else I screwed up or
whatever maybe a radios are
out uh I need to be able to tell it like
it is because in
combat you've got to be able to execute
and bring out these Lessons Learned in
particular a lot of times there's young
wingmen in the in the in the crowd the
new wingman that just started flying on
your mission if I as a senior leader if
I'm the flight lead the first thing we
do is we admit our mistakes we expose
our chest to daggers we call it saying
okay men and women you know wingman I
screwed up today I we had a radar Trail
departure in the weather and I didn't
brief the air speeds on it that's why we
got too close or I didn't breef an
alternate Airfield I forgot to do that
in a mission and you know what if we had
an emergency over you know Bosnia or
herina or
wherever I wouldn't have known where to
go h
and Joe I expect you next time to tell
me and correct that when I expose my
mistakes isn't that going to facilitate
more communication from everybody else
sure yeah and it's also going to
facilitate communication from the senior
leader so debriefing going over
everything that went right and went went
wrong finding out the root cause of
those problems why do we mess up today
and take that as a lesson learned so
that everybody in that group can learn
from it and then execute it better next
time sometimes that means taking that
lesson learned if there was a trend item
and going back into our training if
we're consistently screwing up radar
Trail departures maybe we need to train
on that in the simulator maybe we need
to have a mission and a training mission
to go out that if you're consistently
messing up a cold call or uh failing to
properly deliver or give a product
demonstration maybe in the training
department we need to fix that so take
the Lessons Learned put it into back
into the organization so that everybody
else can learn on it and then change
your training and when you change your
training you'll be able to change your
execution and make it better so is that
something when you go in and work with
clients you you talk to them about doing
debriefing is that something that you
find most people aren't doing most
people uh brief their missions but they
forget to do it on the ground and
sometimes they'll sit down and they'll
talk about it briefly for a minute or
two over a cup of coffee but it has to
be a process there has to it has to be a
specific detail process that goes
through and it takes a uh a good amount
of time to do that so quickly tell us
about your analogy or your acronym of wi
what does it mean to win when stands for
work it now like I said before the more
you sweat in peace the less you bed more
the winners in life understand that it
takes sweat and sacrifice that it takes
work and they don't put it all till
tomorrow they do it today they do it now
I think it's very important to think
about that when it comes to success in
life so many of us we put it off till
tomorrow what we can do today and we
understand that winning takes work and
sacrifice and we do it now I think
that's a good mindset to have uh and
when you start working it now you can
sit back and and reap the rewards and
benefits of all the sacrifices and and
and relax and have fun because that's
what it's all about enjoyment you have a
book in the works called wingman yes
tell us about that wingman how to
transform relationships into victories
and business and life it basically talks
about some of the things we mentioned
today but about at the end of the day
it's about building relationships and
caring about other people uh having
compassion and being able to solve the
problems and challenges in your life
both in business business and your
personal life is how we win and wingman
is about those relationships as a phight
Aila Top Gun whatever it doesn't mean
anything uh if it's not about the people
that help me get to where I am today and
that's what the book's about it's great
for business and personal development
and I'm excited to write it and I'm
excited for you to read it all right and
it's coming out uh 2006 you're going get
yeah end of 2006 December it should be
up and running and I hope you hold me
accountable to that because it's I got
to start working it now I will I will
appreciate it uh glad we have the time
together and that uh America gets to see
a little bit of the guy that I've
already known for a couple years so
appreciate you being here with us Chris
you're an awesome Wing man thanks man to
see Chris's interview with Jim ran which
was the last time Jim ran did a video
interview check it out right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there what
you're about to watch is the last video
interview that Jim ran ever did he sits
down with Chris Widner to talk about how
to get the right mentors set meaningful
goals and stop being broke